joe biden's mental capacity
was a strip club
what are the girls wearing
are they fully are they almost fully
dressed
a jogging suit
are they full of
are they showing any skin at all or
are they just yeah i think they're
walking out there fully dressed
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my
god
listening to all of your podcasts yeah
and they're good thank you i love it
we throw caution to the wind here
we thought we don't
know
i can barely hear george can you crank
up the freaking sound luis
[Music]
he
yes
i'm with here with gail carrillo
hola
yes sir
how are you my friend i'm doing well yo
was uh one of the detectives that uh was
um
in capturing the night stalker richard
ramirez
bono
yes really yeah yeah yeah that was my
case matter of fact i was just back in
miami
uh two weeks ago talking to the cops
over there uh giving them a lecture on
the case
my brother's a cop that's cool god bless
him good for him
good people back there yeah
when yo man next time you come into
miami give i'll give you my number give
me a call we've got a we've got a really
cool little ranch here we got horses and
[ __ ] like that it's really fun oh that'd
be a great time thank you so thank you
for the invitation um um
what uh
where has television gone news-wise
let me say something
it's it's a rough are we did we start
are we going i think then we start yeah
yeah we're going to introduce them oh
introduce rick okay great rick was one
of my favorite i used to watch him on
cnn and i think yeah yeah joining us
today on the podcast we've got uh
journalist radio host author and host of
the rick sanchez news podcast rick
sanchez
thanks guys
um
there's a there's have you ever seen a
i mean i'm sure in in maybe in
uh and some other uh
third world countries uh seeing a
country so divided when it comes to news
no
it's dangerous what's going on right now
we're living in two completely different
silos and the people over here don't
know what the people over here are
watching and the people over here don't
know what the people over here are
watching and and it's absolutely crazy
um and it's dangerous as hell and you
know my friend saw trujillo he's my
partner in this thing and he always says
i feel like there's like people are like
talking about a civil war and [ __ ]
that's crazy you know
if you look at some of the things that
are being sent amongst followers of a
certain particular
kind that they're all buying ammunition
and they are looking at uh civil
disobedience
as if they were not as if it were
nothing i mean the fact that they've
taken they took over the capital and
people were killed and and all of that
and it's just uh um
they're patriots
you know they're patriots well and and
they're unified by their hate of
mexicans
so
that's basically what got it all started
i should have been on this dude named
trump came down an escalator and he said
they're criminals and they're rapists
and i suppose some are good people and
you know who he was talking about he was
talking about us he was talking about
all freaking latinos
now and in the past and who've ever come
to the united states and that is
i mean
it's like you're throwing out a net and
say everybody who agrees with me that
you hate mexicans come on board and you
know what we're gonna do this thing and
and what still pisses me off guys i'm
sorry i know you say i'm doing this
podcast
about that stuff you're right you're
right you're right in with us
that that he did this and that the right
done this and that fox news and all
these other guys and all these bizarre
networks that are propping up
literally spend 80 percent of their
energy talking about the border the
border of the border which means we hate
mexicans we hate mexicans we hate
mexicans i mean but by the way
that could come off the wrong way
i as a latino living in the united
states believe that we should control
our border absolutely okay on the record
nobody's out there saying everybody come
in they can do whatever they want no
pedo
just because you're saying that you
should control the border i also want
the people who are helping this country
the most man look let's do stats
latinos in the united states are the
third fastest growing gdp in the world
if they were a country unto themselves
yes only behind china and india and
ahead of the united states itself
latinos in the united states start more
small businesses latinos in the united
states hire more people than anybody in
the united states i mean the numbers
make you go why the hell would i want to
get rid of these people right give me a
freaking break they are the economy the
backbone of our of our country and and
yeah that that doesn't get heard because
the the guys on the right are saying
we're all a bunch of you know whatever
um
and the guys on the left don't pay us
any mind and don't know how to protect
us with the kind of statistics that i
just spewed out why would somebody shoot
that shot first
why would somebody aim there first
could you george because it's
easy i guess because there's a
differentiation the the vast majority of
people who are undocumented who come to
the united states get off of a plane and
overstay their visas has nothing to hell
to do with the border and most of the
people who come to the united states and
cross the border end up contributing
more to the united states than any other
citizens or non-citizens in the united
states commit less crimes give more
money what was the number now i think
it's 80 billion dollars that
undocumented immigrants give to
americans so they can retire for free
they subsidize
americans ability to collect well to
collect social security
i mean these stats are important
nobody tells these stories and that's
why we're doing this agua media rick
sanchez news thing because you know they
fired me everywhere so i might as well
just start my own damn cover uh uh yeah
you know um i think that's true they
have fired you everywhere um what was
the last place that uh
but but you know i i think that at cnn i
i cnn i think you got
replaced for something that was menial
it wasn't even a it wasn't even a big
deal
yeah it well you know i guess i mangled
my words i shouldn't have said what i
said i was all i was trying to say is
the media in general needs to have more
representation it needs to be more
diverse we need to have latinos in the
media and every time there's an
opportunity they you know they skip us
and go to somebody else and then the
conversation turned into something where
i said something i wish i hadn't said
and that's fine listen man we live in a
country where everybody has the right to
get sued everybody has a right to get
fired
i get that but here's the deal so they
were they fired me some like what 10 12
years ago they still haven't replaced me
there's not a prominent latino on the
news we're 20 of the population we're
less than two percent of the people who
are represented in the national
conversation in the news or in the media
et cetera
econo there's not a rick sanchez at cnn
still there's not one at uh at msnbc
there's not one at fox
i mean give me a break guys i mean don't
you think we should be there not to
mention the fact that you know what
hollywood does right 37 according to the
adenberg study 37 of the latinos in
hollywood are criminals and another 27
are like losers
again i mean it's a pattern that we need
to just like address not because we're
angry nowadays so well maybe a little
bit yeah no because
you know we should say it but why isn't
uh why aren't they out there i mean wha
what are what is uh and you don't know
there's no
i guess i guess if there's not uh um
if there's
you know if there's not someone on there
i don't think if you don't get any
pushback then it's gonna be all right
you know because they think that we're
all sitting around watching telemundo
and univision and we're all grandparents
watching telenovelas and they don't know
that the common age of a latino in the
united states is 11 and the common age
of a non-latino in the united states is
58 which is an unbelievable number they
don't know that 80 of us are us citizens
they don't know that 95 95 of latinos in
the united states speak english under
the age of 41. they don't know these
things so they think we're all just a
bunch of [ __ ] you know and uh because
they think that way and because to a
certain extent we allow them to think
that way because we're not the kind of
people who go out and protest and stuff
it's not who we are you know my dad your
dad they lose their job they just go get
another one in the hell with it that's
right
report that right
they're not looking for attention
they're not looking for um uh they're
looking for a place to go every day
yeah exactly and i feed my wife and my
kids and get the hell out of here you
say hello but every once in a while you
got to look at this stuff and you say
you know
man i mean
we are we've been here since before the
pilgrims first of all latinos you know
if you look at it from you know espanola
and that [ __ ] we we got here in what uh
1565
the pilgrims were in what 1620. we we
celebrated thanksgiving and sang
agusting
and they celebrated it in plymouth rock
but no but nobody knows this same as if
you go to the you know like
who we are in santa in in new mexico i
mean these are
these are important
things that people just need to
understand that we're just as american
as any other americans out there why is
that sometimes we don't feel it man why
is there a need why is there a need for
someone to feel better
and more important or or think that
they're better than someone else
because if we are going to be the fabric
of the united states if for nothing else
we we need to be also as as we grow in
the united states we need to be in
boards you know we need to be in the
board room we need to be the ceos we
need to be in all of those positions
where we probably already kind of
deserve to be as much as anybody else
you know as latinos we shouldn't be
asking for anything more than anybody
else
has but it should be proportional i mean
uh you know going back to what i said a
little while ago george if we're 20 of
the population why are we less than two
percent of the people that we see on tv
why is it that when they talk about
inflation they don't invite one of us
why when they talk about ukraine they
don't invite one of us we have a better
perspective on the world than most
people do because you know i think we're
a little more diverse we bring
experiences from our past our parents
yes so you know i'm a big proponent for
that you know more inclusion for us well
you know
gill is a uh veteran he served uh were
you in the uh army i was in new york he
was in the army and went to uh he served
in vietnam
that's another great statistic guild
will tell you
latinos serve in the military more than
disproportionately to their actual
population that we we serve more
marine corps for example more latinos
than any other court in the
commandant
united
quoted as saying last year i need to
stop latinos from joining because
there's too freaking many of them
i mean
and they want to throw us out guys but
also but also you know we think it's
good to go to the front that's what we
[ __ ] up we're like i'm going to the
front we want to get up there hey you
guys are going to the front we are yeah
let's go
let us up there we'll go to the front
you know uh
but also when you were in vietnam and
you were uh gunning and flying and
shooting
i don't think you saw color no there
weren't nah there there wasn't and and
you saw a guy
tell rick about the the story of your of
your
um army buddy that you saw after all
those years that uh yeah we uh
this is our crime just this past no i
will cry
that past february uh
captain that i flew with in vietnam when
i went to gun ships and i'm flying with
him
he's the first guy that ever chewed my
ass nobody's ever chewed my ass like him
again we're just going hot my gun got
jammed we made a loop we come back i
hadn't unjammed my gun yet made a third
loop and now i'm ready to go when we
landed he came and jumped right in my
ass and told me that
hey when you panic you die
i'm part of a four-man crew
and we need you we need you to be
prepared we need to do this and i just
looked at him
and then he turned and walked away i
never said anything back to him because
everything he said was right it was
absolutely right
i always wanted to find that captain
that that guy
um we found each other on facebook
that's why he's gonna cry and
january of uh this past year this year
we was uh
we i was going back to lecture in uh
arizona he was planning a vacation we
decided we're going to meet
nbc
a kid that grew up with my kid went to
school together he ended up he is now
uh nbc's affiliate in phoenix he was the
guy in charge of the news media back
there
and he follows me on facebook and he
wanted to know hey could we put a camera
crew on you guys when you get together
he did
we met
uh tom tom stemke
good polish guy from sheboygan michigan
and myself
and we met and we cried like babies we
just cried hugged and cried
it was something beautiful and i hadn't
seen him in 53 years
and so we were able to do that
uh to get there was that like gil i mean
i mean
my
god mean i can't even
imagine
what it's like to be in a war uh i've
covered some but it's different
and to hear you say i laughed earlier
panicked every day man right no no you
know i flew every day unless the bird
was down
and
you know it's business you get into it
you know it's like football it's game
day you get in you go out
and sometimes it gets ugly it gets hairy
and you just pray and dear god just get
me out of this one you know and you get
and as soon as you're flying away safely
back to the back to the base it's all
good again you get down re-arm your
plane refuel go into the hooch and turn
on combat on armed forces tv and drink a
beer one of the most dangerous jobs like
in the history of military
worldwide was being a helicopter pilot
in vietnam man yeah according to the
statistics those guys like
they're dropped every day right the the
captain told the news news media guy he
says you know we really didn't know if
we were going to come home that
any time we went out because it was an
extremely dangerous thing and it's just
great to see the guy alive and he's a
good good man today and it was uh
but i have to laugh
uh because you said something early on
in the show you mentioned [ __ ]
and when i was in vietnam everybody had
a nickname and my first name is gill so
my name was g [ __ ]
because i was mexican
you know and i was the only mexican in
the platoon and i was called g [ __ ]
everybody would do eat beans i mean is
it an insult i mean i like no no it
wasn't
kind of cool i think right i mean it's
not it's cruel it worked for me
now i'm fascinated by you gail do you
ever hear people say something to you
that makes you want to retort with
when you i mean i fought for this
country dude i fought for this guy yeah
when do you go there because they're
saying something the only time i wanted
the only time i wanted to say that
was when i first went to the va i was i
was diagnosed diabetic was a diabetic
and they sent me to a doctor the doctor
uh unfortunately for myself or for him i
don't know i got there and he was a
doctor that was from vietnam
and
so
he says okay you're a diabetic i said
okay and i asked him a simple question
because i had a sister that was diabetic
i said does that mean you're going to
give me one of those things to prick my
finger and i test my blood now
and the guy went off on me telling me
i'm not the doctor and he got
he really got got angry
and i just looked and i said hey doc
wait a minute wait a minute i know you
got a tough job and you see people that
are a lot sicker than i am
i said but i have a job that i got to
talk to people too and there's no reason
to be condescending to anybody i asked
you a simple question and because i
challenged now his voice went five
octaves up higher and i said okay time
out it's over with get out of my way i'm
leaving
and he pushed himself in front of the
door
and he said you're not leaving until i
get done with that i said i'm gonna tell
you last time get out of my way or
you're gonna get hurt i promise
get out of my way or you're gonna get
hurt
so he stepped out of the way let me out
and i never went back
and so that's the only time i wanted to
say you piece of [ __ ] i fought i i i got
you here
and now you're going to talk to me like
this that's the only time i've ever
ruined my i don't get mad at anybody who
says good for you
i didn't
and i didn't say didn't say that to them
amongst all the other things that are
wrong with this country why don't why
aren't we taking better care of
the veterans and people who put their
lives on the line
for all of us indiscriminate of color or
race creed age that those guys continue
to
put their lives on the line and they get
back and they can't get the treatment
that they need
yeah because
i i don't know man i think i think a lot
of it has to do with the fact that the
the emphasis from a military standpoint
today in the united states of america
has more to do with how we can make
pratt and whitney happy and how we can
make raytheon happy rather than how we
can make the soldiers the troops who
were actually on the ground fighting
happy and and and the corporatization
of the military you know as eisenhower
warned us a great president about the
military-industrial complex is true
the the guys in those big corporations
who are getting trillions of dollars
and starting really stupid wars like the
war in iraq
are uh controlling things that should be
uh helping the troops but instead
they're helping those guys i will say
this very wealthy people
i will say this about the veterans
administration
yeah you're right i'll say this about
the veterans administration today
because i recently got contacted by the
veterans administration
and by a very very wonderful gentleman
and he said the veterans administration
today is not what it was
back when i had the run-in they're doing
things fine i can tell you
that
i've received nothing but the best
expedient
assistance i can possibly get stuff that
i didn't even know i was
worth had coming to me
i don't know what had come into it it
just
all of a sudden
things are going well and and it's
within two months
two months from
time i started to
actually being rated and it's it's
amazing he says it's the new
uh
new way of doing things started about
four or five years ago well but don't
you think though part of the problem is
i mean i'm just sitting here thinking
out loud with you guys you know as a
bunch of latinos
if
if we won more wars or if we actually
fought wars with the intention of
winning them instead of just being there
long enough to make some people very
wealthy from them the soldiers would not
come back from those entanglements as
messed up as they are because i know if
if i was being given a job but i didn't
understand what my function was it would
mess me up a little bit and 20 years in
afghanistan without a real mission same
as iraq it's got to mess some of these
guys up right
i gotta believe
i'll only speak from the time when i was
in vietnam it's almost as if as i look
in hindsight
they brainwash you you know this is your
goal this is what you got to do you're
fighting for your country this is it and
they have to keep that morale up well it
got to the point
i was there i got there the first the
first week of the ted offense of 1968
february 16th
and so it was it was terrible by the
time i left in march of 69 april 69
uh coming home you'd be flying and we'd
get shot at
and but before we could return fire you
had to call somebody else to get
permission to make sure that it was
not uh
you know that there weren't friendlies
in the area or this was the friendly
village
and one sits here i know we'd sit there
and say so what are we supposed to do
smile
while they're shooting at us
you know so the war was being fought
entirely and even
veterans then were bitter
and so the way things were going on
towards the end when i got there there
was no bitter it was good let's get out
there
let's throw chicken gossips you know
what but i think i think what you said
about
i you know people listen to this i want
them to understand that
um what you said about corporations
being involved in in the military
whether it's the tents the food the
clothes the
uh protection the ammo it's all diverted
to a company that is making money off of
uh the soldiers and off of the war right
rick yeah yeah
no question yeah and and they have
influence in undue influence in in the
senate and in congress etc because
they're the ones who give the biggest
amounts of money in donations to our
politicians and you know as a nation if
we love this country we need to watch
that because it becomes unfair
and you know the average person running
for office in the united states gets 98
of their money from very wealthy
corporations and only two percent of the
money from you know folks like us
so uh yeah they have undue
influence unfortunate manifest wars even
and get people to vote for things that
they normally would go and it's
unfortunate that the people that are
fighting the wars and the people who are
voting are ignorant to this i don't
think people really understand what the
what they're voting for or what's or
what's happening right you figure if
it's uh being done there has to be a
reason why it's being sure and um
why people like rick sanchez get fired
from places like nbc and cnn and fox
news what what freedom has been saying
now would let me i would last 30 seconds
on one of those places because the
biggest advertisers and the people who
sit on the board of nbc and all those
big networks are guys who are also
sitting on the board of raytheon i mean
let's face it i mean i'm not trying to
be critical i love my country i want
this country to succeed but you got to
call things as they are when i see my
son do something wrong i tell him
i love you but you screwed up right you
know and i don't think we do enough of
these guys sometimes you know and things
like this and what are they trying to
accomplish in in in
in news because it's almost like it's
almost like a team now if you're fox
news you're not cnn if you're msnbc
you're not fox you're not uh breitbart
and you and you know you're not uh young
turks so it's almost like uh i would say
a team you're you're committed to your
team and whatever they say on your team
is what you believe
yeah it's an encampment right it's like
we have to be over here saying this
message and we have to be over here
saying this message and it's unfortunate
and most of the people who are in those
places are paid well enough to not want
to leave the job so they'll say whatever
they think needs to be said
i listen i got dear friends at all of
those places obviously like you and the
you know in our business as you know you
and the entertainment and community
comedic business and me and the news
business i got buddies that work at fox
news who don't believe some of the stuff
that i know comes out of their mouth
because i talk to them and i got buddies
at cnn and nbc who kind of are saying
things that i'm going like why would you
say that why are you why are you
reporting that but not reporting other
things and it's because well you know
some of these guys make pretty good buck
man they give them you could be an
anchor at nbc you could be like an
anderson cooper dude man making 22
million dollars a year just by reading a
freaking teleprompter a couple times a
day that's a pretty good gig of course
you're not going to give that up in the
old days when i was growing up an inc
you know a television a journalist was
like uh you know a high-paid executive
maybe a couple hundred thousand dollars
a year so you know you know this
probably has got something to do with it
george so
so when walter cronkite was like
everybody's uh you know everybody
watched walter cronkite and and all
those guys back there rick what what
what uh
i don't think they had a horse in the
race they were just reporting what
was what the news was they didn't have
an angle they didn't add a slant to the
news it was the news right
here's what i think happened and this is
just my theory
i think what happened was after
watergate there was an emphasis on
confrontational journalism they were
going after anybody who was corrupt or
anybody was doing something wrong i
think a lot of journalists back then
maybe went a little too far
and there were business people who were
probably attacked or had these
confrontational interviews and they all
kind of got together and said you know
what the media is a little bit out of
control let's start our own media sort
of thing
and those very conservative forces
inside the united states they started
coming up with think tanks and their own
media companies vis-a-vis fox news let's
present a conservative perspective and
convince americans that they need to be
on our side well they really started off
george as just a bunch of rich guys who
wanted to make sure their taxes were
kept down so you know they were going to
push that message but then they started
pushing a message to get regular
americans real americans over on their
side which was let's talk bad about
blacks let's distance you from latinos
or mexicans or
and little by little they created this
thing called fox news and all these
other entities that are on the right
and when they did that they took all the
angry white people with them which left
nbc and cnn with the non-angry white
people right so then they started
programming to keep that audience and
they programmed to them as kind of angry
minorities who are angry at the white
people so you got you got networks doing
news for angry white people box and
you've got news doing and you've got
networks doing news for
angry black people msnbc and that's what
we've ended up with and you're
absolutely right it's siloed silos are
not good they're not good enough family
they're not good in a business etc and
they're certainly not good for our
country but that's what we got right now
you're right you're right and as we uh
and as we go no let me ask you this so
so so you and your podcast and what you
do like what uh how can people find you
and and uh how often do you do you are
you doing your shows and and because i
think it's it's very refreshing isn't it
it's refreshing to
to hear someone speak yeah so freely a
different perspective that doesn't mean
we're right all the time we just give
perspectives that i think are important
we like to call them latino truths
that's what we do we do latino truths
it's called
our company is called agua media
and you know like you said cnn fired me
and i started a 4.4 billion dollar
company and my wife said get out of the
house go do something so now we're gonna
do this me and
saul trujillo we started agua media this
show that i do is called rick sanchez
news
uh it's called rick sanchez news you
know it's on it's on spotify it's on
apple and
all that stuff and we're we're getting a
lot of traction we really just started a
while ago but we're seeing a lot of
people who are jumping on board and
saying when you finally somebody is
saying some of the things that i've
always wanted to say or maybe some of
the things that should have been said by
some of these folks like the anderson
coopers but you know they don't defend
us so i will we will you know and and i
know you get it i know you guys get it
yeah and we're not trying to be mean but
there's some things that you know got to
be said that's it because it almost like
uh you know when fox news or when you
said you know after after watergate that
almost the gloves have come off on on
news you know now the gloves have come
off on
on on on situations uh explain to us
what uh taking classified documents back
to lagomar means
politically
well there's no question that those are
stolen documents because
i said this in my podcast yesterday
somewhere in south florida over the
weekend a young african-american man was
followed by security to his car when
they got to his car they found a pair of
nikes when they asked him for a receipt
for the nikes he wasn't able to present
a receipt for the nike and they had
information that he may have taken him
from the store they immediately
handcuffed and took that young man to
jail he was about a 19 or 20 year old
young african-american who had appeared
had stolen property and they took him to
jail there's a billionaire who lives in
palm beach florida not too far from
where that young african-american was
taken they found out that he had stolen
government documents in his home they
didn't arrest him they called him on the
phone they said look i'm sure there's an
explanation just do us a favor return
them and there will be no problems and
we need you to return them by a certain
date instead he returned half and kept
half and that billionaire did not know
that there were cameras and a
confidential informant inside that hotel
or that lagomar hotel that he owns so
they knew that this was there so they
decided to go back in now and they've
taken those things back
and they found that it was stolen
property but yet that billionaire has
not yet been arrested and we're still
waiting to see if you will
that's what bothers america whether it's
hillary trump whether it's hillary
clinton or donald trump or
who knows who there are two different
systems of justice in america there's
one for that young african-american who
seem to have stolen a pair of nikes and
one for a billionaire who lives in palm
beach and that's not right and that's
what makes people mad on both sides
whether you're cheering for donald trump
or you're cheering for uh or against
hillary clinton and a trump supporter
would say what about him having the
documents or only returning half
how in their mind do they reconcile that
that's that's good for america
it's the thing that you and i were
talking about before that we latinos
can't stand victimization oh it's just
because i'm latino oh it's just because
i'm trump oh it's just because you don't
like me you know what i mean after a
while that thing gets a little bit thin
and that's basically the only argument
that we're really hearing at this point
is that somehow
the justice department and the fbi
director who by the way voted for trump
and was appointed by trump decided one
day that he was going to investigate
trump which makes no sense whatsoever
right and as far as uh biden you know
who's you know not the brightest bulb in
the uh on the block no no but but but uh
he's not gonna be doing the best he can
he's just an old guy
but he had nothing to do with that and
that's the other argument that they're
making that somehow the president
assigned the fbi and the justice
department to go after that
it it's not a good argument but they
tend to follow the lead from okay trump
and some of his if joe biden's uh if joe
biden's mental capacity
was a strip club
what are the girls wearing
are they fully are they almost fully
dressed
a jogging suit
are they showing any skin at all or
are they just yeah i think they're
walking out there fully dressed
how do we end up with this though how do
we end up with a guy named trump and a
guy named biden as the two
candidates
i do have one greatest country on earth
man
it's i just i mean i know a lot of
really smart people
and they could all do a better job than
both they don't they're not getting
understood they're not getting up there
they're not i think it says it's been
poor how far back do we have to go until
when the candidates were poorly planned
out like
you know if you lose the election and
you have a republican that the democrat
side would be like we got to start
grooming somebody
to get into the race and i don't believe
that that's that that's happening right
now
i don't believe that that we're prepared
to go forward
um i i worry about the fact that we
don't
have enough
real juice from americans in general
when it comes to
being involved in the system i i don't
know if they want us to be this way but
you know my kids are like dad
it's all fixed come on yeah and i'm like
no if you get involved then dad come on
i mean it's you this this is all
predetermined what would work better so
what we have is we've got basically any
the only people who vote in this country
are like 65 to 80 or 90 you know yeah
and that means that we're not we're not
hooked in and and we should be darn it
what what works better what do you think
works better um than having a president
is there is there
you know there's companies
coca-cola uh does well they're around
the world they run a business you know
is is this is this uh structure that
we've set up is it uh
are we done with it should we adjust it
do we have a president
well i think one of the things is the
electoral college is a little bit of a
you know you guys are in california and
you've got just as many senators as
wyoming does and they got a hundred what
do they have 300 000 people who live
there i mean that's like one one
hundredth of the population of
california and yet you get the same
representation they get the same
representation that you get and the
electoral college was said came up with
this yeah and it was seven easy how many
years
ago about
yeah like 230 some at this point you're
not talking to rick sanchez don't look
at me i'm i'm just an everyday mexican
but also people i'm a mexican in a blue
suit yeah you know i don't know yeah but
i spent my life doing news and stuff and
thinking about all of these things so i
do think sometimes that we need to
address some of the things that people
are afraid to talk about and for some
reason why don't we have these
conversations about some of these things
in an open and honest way not not to
make anybody feel bad or accuse anybody
of anything so on the country we should
fix our problems uh the company that you
guys started what's the how a medium i
want agua media
what are you guys are you guys into
entertainment is it news is it
interviews
is it uh music movies yeah my mine is
like news and commentary uh and then we
have uh another show hosted by uh kathy
fernandez and she does more of a a
spiritual healing helping people kind of
get through their day then we have
another one which is like a true crime
horror show and we've got another five
to six shows coming up on the pipeline
and uh yes obviously
looking for the right comedian that
hopefully you can suggest to us yes why
do you think that people are fascinated
by uh true crime
because it
because it
makes us
see the things
that
we don't
uh experience in our own lives
and everybody
every single human being on earth
loves
hearing a story about somebody who's
worse off than them
it's like no matter how bad my life is
and my life sucks right i'm not saying
my life sucks i'm saying if i'm a human
being thinking my life sucks i lost my
job i got this my wife my old lady
doesn't like me look i say right
whatever it is
i'm gonna sit down tonight and i'm gonna
watch a situation where some guy got
busted and he's going to jail or he's
being investigated and he can't sleep
and you know what that was worse than me
so you don't want to sleep really well
today you know what i've asked that
question a lot and i and i believe that
that answer is is close to it because i
remember when we worked during the you
know when i worked during the day and
you would gravitate towards things where
and i still do on on uh on youtube it's
just
i i think the thing that drives it now
is uh true crime or i i just think that
people
something as simple as a crime you don't
need a great big deal of intelligence
they think jump in there and solve it
everybody's looking to try and help
solve the big mystery they think they've
got the answer they can get involved
without really being out there on the
front line
because it is a big deal and i know i'm
being contacted constantly about doing
more true crime stuff so it's out there
rick why would it oh yeah it's the
biggest it's the biggest uh space in
podcast and one of the ones that has the
best cpms or whatever the heck all this
stuff is because for some reason it gets
a big draw
and and and people do really like that
rick what's making what's making these
kids at a young age
uh
you know get weapons and go and destroy
uh other people's lives and their own
life like what what is what are making
these kids go in there and i think
they have to know that their life is
over the minute that they step out of
their
house or step into a school or go
wherever uh uh
i mean i you know at that age in high
school
i was
you know i was
i don't know man i just i just think you
know we lead the the world in
uh school shootings and even at mass
shootings
wha what's happening in people's psyche
well first of all i do believe that we
need to be able to come up with some
kind of system i don't want to take
anybody's guns away but we should have
some kind of regulations as to who could
buy them and when and whether somebody
who has psychological issues and they're
documented should be able to be allowed
to go to a gun show and buy a gun or
whether people under the age of 21
should just willy-nilly be able to go
and buy guns i mean every great cop that
i ever when i was a cop reporter for
many many years i was a cop reporter in
south florida that's kind of how i made
my name in this business and i remember
most of the police officers i talked to
back then said look if it was up to us
there's too many we see too many people
out here with guns that shouldn't have
guns and they're doing a lot of harm so
yeah there's no question guns are part
of the issue but when you say george the
the when you narrow the question to the
age of some of these people that are
doing this
i i don't know man i disagree with you a
little bit i think that um
i think it would be harder to grow up
today than it was when you and i were
just a bunch of cholos growing up yeah
because
the stuff that they get now the
messaging the the you know the the this
thing and the laptop and the tech and
the com and the world moving so fast
it's just
you know i i think it's befuddling i
think it's confusing i i think it makes
them a little bit crazy
and you know i used to climb trees and
go to the park and get in fights with my
buddies and
and and play ball and you know that
stuff and i don't see kids doing that
anymore i ride by parks and they're
empty i do have it
inside
i do have an opinion and and that was
when i was a kid growing up if you got
in trouble with the cops you got in
trouble with in school
parents were quick to beat the [ __ ] out
of you it was your fault don't blame it
on the school don't blame it on the cops
and then we went from that to now
everything is everybody else's fault
and there isn't they're not held to any
kind of resp
they're not held to any responsibilities
at all they get in trouble oh it's miho
you know the school it was your fault
why didn't you what what are you
teaching them in school
why are you allowing to get that you
should be there in school you should be
taking
it's uh there is my mom used to beat the
crap out of me oh yeah go ahead and say
that i mean i know you might get letters
on or something but you know she did and
my dad was a very strict disciplinarian
as well so and my mom would sit at the
front door and we would be out and they
said we were supposed to be home at a
certain time my dad by the way my dad
was funny he used to sleep in my bed so
if i came home late i had to wake his
ass up
i would turn on the light and i was like
you know and i'm jumping up and your
beard was like yeah
yeah i see i knew you were going to do
this you know and my mom would sit at
the front door and she'd say enter
you know
i'm not gonna do anything to you come on
in and then and then all of a sudden i'm
okay i'm gonna come whack you know as
you're coming through the door i mean it
was just the way we were raised and that
yeah that's what and and that doesn't
happen they're not held for anything
they've done it's always somebody else
and that's the way they've been brought
up and and i i've listened to people say
you are what you eat you are this it's
your environment the area you've been
brought up
i think it all starts in the home and
ends in the home
you know it's the way you were the way
you were brought up there is no respect
out anymore
and
you've got to monitor
i think the phones and the electronics
give you a false sense of
of uh
uh that you're actually reaching out to
to people like you know you if you're
walking you see somebody taking a selfie
or they're or they're talking on
facetime or they're doing something and
it gives people uh
uh
i i think a sense that they're that
every person is
i don't want to say important but that
it that it matters now that you say that
when we were young growing up
you had gangs
and gangs the reason gangs were formed
were to protect one another they became
your family you relied on each other and
you didn't care about anything else
other than your gang member friends
now
you get out there they have social media
which is just an extension of the game i
have all these people that are giving me
advice all social media is an extension
of gangs exactly yeah
uh yeah
you know there's a word that we have in
spanish it's called verguinza
verguinsa is a very powerful word right
for us latinos right it means shame
and you you don't shame your name you
don't shame your family you don't shame
your mother you don't shame your father
and if you do expect an ass kicking
right you got to get your butt whipped
because you just don't do that anymore
and
that's so important in our culture and i
almost see
you know i see politicians nowadays who
screw up or do something you know
like like this guy uh
matt gates we did a podcast on this guy
matt gates he's being investigated by
the feds for taking a 16 or 17 year old
girl across state lines and having sex
with her right i'm not saying that
that's in the news you can google it
right
and if somebody were accusing me of
something like that man i wouldn't show
my face i would not be holding news
conferences i would try and if it's a
lie i would be screaming hey this is
crap this isn't true and i would be
dealing with it in court the guy's
holding news conferences every day and
and and talking about uh you know about
biden and this and then yeah an abortion
issue
man shut up show some berguenza yeah
what happened to that what happened to
that i mean
you know
i think as a latino
that's one of the most important things
that we get from from our parents from
our culture don't shame the family don't
do something so stupid out there that's
going to make people think less of all
of us so well you were when you were
growing up when you were growing up um
what did you gravitate to did you play
sports or because i would imagine that
somebody like you would with uh you know
an outspoken opinion there's an
intelligence to you that that um
uh who were you upsetting in your early
teens
was actually a pretty good kid i mean
you know i was i grew up in ambario here
in hialeah florida i'm a cuban kid i
came as an immigrant when i was two my
parents never made more than ten
thousand dollars a year combined income
my dad worked in a hotel
my mom sewed shoes in a factory that was
one of my dad's jobs so all i ever got
from my parents was you know love but
certainly nothing materialistic and i
kind of made my way because i played
football and i was pretty good at it and
i got a football scholarship and i was
able to go to minnesota and there i got
a cbs news scholarship because i was i
was a pretty good student
um and and then i found
you know the idea of writing and
communicating
as effectively as i could
and the fact that i was bilingual and i
could do it in either language and
switch back and forth in spanish and in
english you know made people think that
that was pretty cool so that helped me
along the way as well
so yeah i mean i played football and i
and and and i was i was always a little
bit of a i always kind of fancied myself
as a little bit of an overachiever um
even though i grew up with nothing i
mean absolutely nothing but there's a
lot of us like that i mean
i'm not trying to make my story special
because among if you go around the
country there's latinos who've done 50
times what i've done you know guys like
you george you know well there's also
you know whatever color you are that
um you know this country should be for
everyone to want to do better and not
i you know i wanted to do better but i
didn't want to begrudge
someone else wanting to do better i
never even thought about them doing
better only thought about myself never
hated the fact that somebody other than
me was doing better and i think that's
what where we are now we're we're a bit
of you know like those
that it's just so much it's so negative
and it's so detrimental to a free
society that you know it's you almost
don't want to pop your head i mean how
many creative people are uh are we
stopping from being creative because
they don't want to poke their head out
oh yeah yeah because we we
we we have lost the capacity for being
gracious
for being gracious as losers or as
winners
or as brothers and sisters for someone
who had just done something well and
deserves a pat on the back yeah just
like when they do something not so well
they probably deserve to be told the
truth but it seems like you're right man
nowadays we don't tell people the truth
when we hear them say something we wish
they hadn't said we don't pat each other
enough on the back
and we we're always looking for things
that are wrong instead of things that
are right and
there is a negativity almost a cynicism
that has overcome us that i i don't know
i don't know where why that comes from
just as americans you know and we feel a
lot of that as latinos in particular
because you know we get a lot of heat
for stuff we don't deserve
so but you know turn the other cheek but
jesus said uh uh
but but uh people in uh in miami and in
florida are a lot of latinos are on the
right
uh were they always uh were they always
red or did someone turn them red
no they weren't always red the cubans
who came to miami after the castro
revolution were democrats
and uh they they got sucked up
in uh that maybe i should put it this
way the democratic party's inability
to uh
cast aspersions among
the communist governments that they came
from and the republicans ability ronald
reagan in particular he's where he's
where it all started ronald reagan came
to miami embraced the cuban community
and said i am with you and i am going to
take down fidel castro and
you know together we're going to forge
an anti-communist world here etc etc etc
you know a lot of that was kind of just
you know
um
political speak yeah which then
everybody did since him you know
today to be elected in florida you have
to come to miami and you have to tell
the cubans that you hate castro and you
hate communism and then they'll they
might vote for you unfortunately because
the republicans were the first to do it
they've kind of
drawn it out
and you know it's become it's become
part of the the mantra if you will who
was the mayor that had told us because
there's no difference between a democrat
and a republican when it comes to
communism but for some reason they
bought into it who was the mayor in
florida that had a little bit of juice i
think it was the alien gonzalez thing
that
uh he was kind of a he he was a name uh
starting to come up pinellas yes alex
pinellas yes
was there during during that time he was
kind of out of the other right
well um
you know i interviewed bill clinton
during that uh i interviewed clinton i
interviewed reagan i interviewed carter
i interviewed uh wow obama and one of my
most
i'll never forget my interview with bill
clinton because we just went toe-to-toe
i've never seen a human being who loves
a fight more than that guy and at the
time i was telling him that he was wrong
in how he handled uh you know elian
gonzalez because ellie gonzalez
was being used by the castro government
and when his father said i want him back
he didn't really want him back because
if he really wanted him back why did he
let him leave right right what he
changed his mind all of a sudden so and
i was trying to tell uh president
clinton that
and uh and i said look
you you got you got taken you you you
don't understand you know mr president
and he started yelling at me and then
telling me that i was wrong and i
started telling him that he was wrong
and i mean i was supposed to interview
the guy for just like uh you know 10
minutes and we were still going at it
about a half hour into it and they
almost had to like pull him back because
he was so engaged in the conversation
because he was convinced he was right
but i'll never forget and it was all
about alien gonzalez
and to this day i admire clinton for
he's
he loves to spar intellectually uh more
than any other president i intervi ever
interviewed and uh the other only one
was gorbachev i once said to mikhail
gorbachev
when you went to cuba mr president and
fidel castro pulled the uh
the the red carpet and said you could
leave on your own we're not going to
even give you a state uh you know escort
and i said how did that make you feel
and gorbachev turns to me and he says
that's your problem you cubans you
cubans are obsessed with castro
everything is about castro the only
reason
that that castro is a famous person is
because you make him that
why are you asking me questions about
castro and he got all pissed off at me
and then he just kind of walked away it
wasn't always so that's true
those are the two times i interviewed
presidents and they got pissed off and
for my question yeah so there you go
yeah yeah amazing it is it's fascinating
to me he just came awesome
congratulations
uh yeah yeah
uh so so so the media group you see it
uh um
in original programming and and podcasts
and and and things like that
well yeah i mean
i think we're going to produce right now
three episodes um
uh each one will be twice a week mine is
three times a week
and i think the key for us
is to try and tell the stories through a
wider angle lens because as latinos we
bring different experiences than most
non-latinos in this country we just see
the world a little bit differently
because of our own experiences
and we think that makes a difference in
how we tell stories i mean one of the
reasons george lopez is considered one
of the best comedians in this in the
united states
it has a lot to do with the fact that
you're latino because you you bring
this to the story
that which you are which comes from your
soul
and just like george lopez was able to
succeed and i in my own way maybe was
able to succeed in you know in in news
we need to see more of that and and
that's why we think by doing a a true
crime podcast hosted by a latino written
by a latino by by doing uh political
segments hosted and written by latinos
and uh by doing all these types of
different podcasts that exist exists out
there hosted and written by latinos
um well for one thing it'll give 20 of
the country a place to go if they want
to hear latino voices and for another
all those people that we call latino
plus who are latinos will get to hear
who we are and get to hear our stories i
think we're going to hear that we speak
english we don't sit around watching
telenovelas every night i still think
that works i still think that we're
finding that audience amongst ourselves
you know
i still think that uh that us as podcast
uh listeners and and uh watchers that
we're still
finding that that and that in our cars
and at work on the weekends or on walks
that you could find this entertainment
uh much more enjoyable than uh than than
listening to music or something that you
become uh accustomed to like try and you
try something new
yeah this whole podcast thing is really
entertaining i i plan my days around my
jogs with a podcast i mean
i i laugh my ass off listening to you
guys on your podcast uh and then i
switch over and i listen to the new york
times uh podcast the daily and then i
listen to wapo uh so i mean i i plan my
day around my comedy podcast my news
podcast
uh my true crime podcasts and you know i
try and get in as many as i can
obviously once you start
you get busy with your day and stuff but
i think it's going to be the future i
mean i think everybody wants to just go
to get their entertainment out of this
little
box
whenever they want and i don't think
it's going to be less i think it's going
to be more don't you if you look at if
you look at television you have to be
in a stationary place to watch it
uh you have to be at home in front of
your you know in your bed or or but i
don't think that we live like that
anymore and i think that you're right in
saying that that we'll find it on our
phones and we'll find it on airplanes
and you find it uh more places than
than than when we used to say
i can't wait to go home to watch whether
it was mike douglas for me or dinah
shore or merv griffin or any of those
things that you can just
find now through youtube and through
podcasts
now um
at your fingertips
well for you it was probably inglebert
humperdinck right
home to watch
i love i love the big dinker i i found
myself more um
you know um as a chicano in that time
into seals and crofts and uh the doobie
brothers and more than ranchera music
you know then then
uh then i would say um you know of
mariachi music
or uh mexican music but i was we were in
the ted nugent who was a friend of mine
you know he's hard right
but uh yeah
so [ __ ] what that's what i say yeah
like
he and i talk and i take the guys that i
went to high school with to go see him
and he's great to them and it's about
the music and not his [ __ ] politics
and rick
you know nobody knew how anybody voted
in the la [ __ ] 40 years ago they
didn't give a [ __ ] you didn't speak
politics at the table you didn't talk
religion and you didn't have
everybody kept to their p's and q's as
you would say and now
everybody has to know what used to what
used to go
unknown they want to know where you are
i see these bumper stickers and i'm
thinking who the [ __ ] cares man
why are you putting all your [ __ ] out
there like that i mean
uh i get it you know i belong to the pta
of my school or something like that
but everybody's bumper stickering their
lives nowadays my kid got an a i voted
for trump i'd hate trump i like this guy
i
man
why do you think that matters to
everyone why would you put all that
stuff out there about yourself you know
is there is together is there an
insignificance that people feel if they
feel like their opinion isn't being
heard it never used to be like that and
i think like you said i think this goes
to saying
that my opinion will be heard on
neighbor next door or whatever [ __ ]
social app that you list that you're
watching or listening to that you know
somebody giving away a cat my old lady
gets that
next door app or something yeah whatever
the heck it's called and i'm sitting
here and i'm laughing at some of the
stuff that those people are like
complaining oh my god it's like
listen i'm sure guys just gonna
masturbate like this i'll tell you why i
like this podcast thing that you that
we're all doing
uh and that i think to a certain extent
really is the future it it's more
intimate there's no script here there's
no teleprompter i mean we're sharing
ideas based on our own experiences and
hopefully learning something from each
other
and i think that's so healthy compared
to you know listening to some dude on
some network reading a teleprompter to
you that was written by i know i worked
there 70 elders or so but you know that
when rick was on so much more real when
i used to watch him on cnn he would do
that he would use his hands and he was
very much into the screen and you were
like i like i i i
when i was in my dressing room when i
was doing my talk show i would watch you
all the time
and i just found it very enjoyable that
that that uh that you were that way and
to see you now after so many years and
to still see you that way uh kudos man
respect to you yeah i remember you and i
phil kent called me one day and he goes
george lopez we got george lopez he's
gonna do a talk show for us and i said
really phil that's so awesome
and then he was going to invite you to a
basketball game we were going to go
watch the atlanta hawks play together me
you and phil
and then we did and then there was
another one and
and the
videos knowing that you were going to be
a part of my team made me feel so cool
man i was honored and then i i'm a fan
of yours i think he asked you so do
people know
who he is and you said phil
he has a [ __ ] show named george lopez
he was the nerdiest son of a [ __ ] i've
ever known but you know hey it is what
it is he was the boss there i i read
turner i thought that uh my tenure there
at uh at tbs
might have been uh
a skewed by some some politics there you
know
that that would be mine too my friend
and and you know what um
i was so pissed off when
that
did not come to fruition or when it
ended or whatever it did i it was one of
the first things
that set me off that started me on this
train toward
this company is not as diverse as they
say they are and they talk a big game
and one day i'm this is going to get out
and it did and i got fired so
i think you may have led to my firing
george you owe me a couple of bucks on
this i probably do but but you know no
one left the show during we found out
kind of uh in june that we weren't
coming back and i think the last shows
were kind of in the beginning of august
and nobody left
to find another job until the show was
over and when it was over
they gave us 36 hours to clear out the
offices which i thought was a bit funny
jesus
you know i thought it was yeah yeah
that's how they told you i mean
yeah
and i mean you know you had prince on
the show i mean i i mean i had uh your
show was fantastic i watched it most
people watched it i don't understand why
they missed why they could shoot it the
way they did and what did they tell you
um i think that they got sold a bill of
goods on conan o'brien that wasn't true
and yeah once they moved me to uh
midnight where they didn't need conan
but i also think that jay leno uh going
to 10 o'clock
once he was relieved of his duties as
the tonight show host and having to go
back on tv when he should have just
taken his money and gone away set
everything in motion
if he had just gone away
i'm not sure if i would still be there
now but it wouldn't have ended the way
it ended i think these guys the
executives that they got sold uh a story
that wasn't true and they all bought
into the story
yeah
yeah and and i i
i don't like conan o'brien to this day
because of that but that's because i'm a
pissed off latino who wants to talk
about failing the other day when you did
the promo there's a lot of uh yeah
there's a lot of failing up and uh
you know
i would i would like the opportunity to
fail up at least one time in my in my
life in my career i want to fail well
they told me you know they said you know
uh
you're a big ratings getter sanchez so
every time we've got a hole in prime
time we're just gonna stick you there so
you can raise the ratings and they did
it when they got rid of campbell brown
and they did it when they got rid of
paula's on
they put me there but then they replaced
me with somebody else and then finally
the last time was they had put me there
and and we were doing really phenomenal
ratings the highest ratings in the
network at the time
and then they said you know what we're
gonna we're gonna save you for the next
time we're gonna give that job now that
eight o'clock prime time show we're
gonna give it to elliot spitzer the
former somewhat disgraced uh ex-governor
of new york
and and that's when i went on my little
tirade i wanted a radio show and i said
you know this isn't fair and then they
fired me the next day so you know it was
kind of like that i mean yours was conan
o'brien mine was elliott spitzer conject
cavalry
you know even jack cafferty and the
cafferty file
that this guy would prepare these
stories that had a beginning a middle
and an end and just was it three minutes
at the end of an hour
i mean
pretty impre i mean you know you guys
were doing
that's that's that's a news person doing
their work you know on the day that
bernard shaw got rest his soul uh passed
away bernard shaw and you guys were
you were newsmen news people yeah
yeah we were doing we were doing serious
news and getting serious ratings and and
and one of the cool things i remember
john klein calls me up to his office the
president of cnn up at the time warner
building where you did all your deals
and
and klein calls me up one day and he
goes i want you to know something
your show is now
the first show
in the history of the network that's had
the highest non-white ratings you're
getting latinos you're getting
african-americans you're getting
everybody that we've always wanted to be
able to reach and part of it was the
whole social media thing we were doing
but it was pretty cool to be told that
by the president of the network that
we're doing you know these ratings and
then and then i go and talk to the other
dude the president of uh turner or
whatever
and he says to me i said you know john
says and my ratings are good and he says
yeah but ratings don't matter here
because we live by subscriptions which
is true the only thing they care about
is how many people are subscribed that
watch them
and he literally told me ratings don't
matter i was like
what i mean what the hell
if my show's doing better ratings than
the other one that doesn't matter no it
doesn't matter okay then i guess it
doesn't matter
well i love seeing you man thank you it
was wonderful to uh
to reconnect with you i think as always
uh i i love your uh spirit i love how
you uh uh present yourself and uh i will
be a listener of your uh podcast and a
follower of your media
well you know what you should be is can
you can you come i would love to return
the favor and interview you as well
absolutely uh you know uh i would love
to do that man i'm i'm a big fan of you
guys i appreciate it i i'm doing a show
at nbc right now with my daughter mayan
my uh my
my my one child and she's cute as a bug
i love it i've been watching it i think
it's fantastic and i love the the
chemistry between you guys and
the the [ __ ] she says about you is funny
[Laughter]
it was a true honor
to meet you and share this time with you
the people that you've been involved
with in your career
uh god bless you
thanks thanks thanks gail i appreciate
it thanks appreciate it guys
you